[Music]
do you consider yourself a number-one
fan of Disney's descendants and
descendants - while you eat early await
and speculate the possibility of a third
edition we came up with some
imperfections and the change is made
between each movie see if you can guess
by dub Cameron is our number one and let
us know your thoughts in the comments if
you love speculating about descendants
and descendants
- make sure to give the video a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel to see
videos like these today we are unveiling
10 inconsistencies between the sentence
2 and the first movie you never saw now
and harry half history we love hearing
about how harsh Mel was when she
completely dumped her first boyfriend
and had no problem replacing uma with
better batter best friend Evie but it
doesn't match up with miles actions and
concerns in her relationship with Ben
sure cast a love spell is definitely no
way to start an honest healthy
relationship but now's manipulation of
Ben pales in comparison to her treatment
of Kerri and uma even the final battle
soon showcases mouths compassion
fighting to save Ben just on the basis
of friendship it's possible not to find
an inconsistency between the way mouth
treats her 3 villain friends and her
past treatment of uma not to mention mal
and Evie sweet duet space between mal
has definitely learned a lot from her
experience as King's girlfriend and her
life on auradon if her newfound sense of
loyalty to her friends is a result of
her experience wouldn't mob have some
remorse for having cast uma and Harry
aside so callously it's difficult to
tell what motivates mouths inconsistent
hatred for her former love interest and
best friends especially in comparison to
how she treats her current friends and
on-and-off-again boyfriend
despite this inconsistency we have to
admit the drama between mal and Harry is
definitely a fun and interesting aspect
of the sequel Audrey asleep or missing
one of the factors that lead to
descendants popularity was the fact that
our villains turned heroes faced several
challenges not only were they trying to
figure out the right
as villains but they were also trying to
integrate themselves into a completely
different environment then now the king
of auradon vouched for the villains next
generation to be given a chance to
choose good or evil for themselves
allowing them the freedom to live
without their imposed banishment to the
Isle of the lost part of the tension was
the fact that Audrey Ben's girlfriend
felt very differently after suffering
from the consequences of the parents
evil there are two inconsistencies
directly related to Sarah Jeffries
character Audrey the first one is a bit
more obvious
Audrey somehow inexplicably disappears
from the cast and descendants to this
begs a question that leads to a more
discrete inconsistency what Kingdom is
Audrey from if both she and Gunn are
members of the monarchy but are not
related how is it that another Kingdom
is never once mentioned though we have a
lot of questions regarding Audrey we
don't have many answers for example why
was Audrey not included in the sequel
but Lani much more of a secondary
character is included in the past either
way
geoffrey displayed nothing but
positivity when she wished her former
cast members the best of luck as they
began filming the sequel demonstrating
grace fit for a queen love spells for
movies about villains both descendants
and descendants to definitely involve a
lot of love in the first movie we saw
how a cookie infused love potion caused
them to break up with his girlfriend
Audrey and instead chants his love for
mal in front of a stand of people we all
remember the scene when mal wonders if
Ben will love her once the spell wears
off which actually happens at that same
moment we find out later that the love
spell wore off once been dipped into the
enchanted Lake apparently some magic
water is all it takes to counteract a
love potion from mouse spell book
however in dissonance 2 when bin finds
himself under yet another love spell mal
breaks it with a simple kiss uma spell
must have come from another source or
else there are multiple ways to undo a
magical spell
it is very confusing to think that even
with the use of magic the ultimate
outcome of a situation is out of Magic's
reach as water from a magical source or
a true love's kiss is all it takes to
foil magics manipulative powers whether
with the use of love spells or without
part of the reason we love descendants -
as much as the first movie is that it
shows us that all teens have crushes
whether it's Jane and Carlos Doug and EB
or mal and then we'll take the romance
with or without the spell Carlos and
dude the dog when it comes to
inconsistencies the list is endless for
Cruella De Vil son Carlos played by the
loveable Cameron voice first of all it's
hard to talk about Carlos without
mentioning his adorable sidekick
dude the dog dude part of the original
cast undergoes a transformation in
descendants - as he is given the ability
to speak the truth inducing sweet was
intended for Carlos so he would have the
ability to speak to Jane about his true
feelings for her this is a pretty big
inconsistency as the sweet not only has
the power to force someone to speak the
truth but it suddenly has the ability to
translate the truth into English even
more of an inconsistency is the fact
that dude is actually played by a female
dog it doesn't really make sense that
Jane and Carlos would be a match
considering they don't exist in the same
world
Cruella is from 1950s era London while
the fairy godmother is from a
make-believe Kingdom this also begs the
question as to why Carlos would be
afraid of dogs in the first place seeing
as how his mom had such a lethal
affinity for them we also wonder why
every character is from a Disney family
while dude has no affiliation whatsoever
wooden lady from lady in the [ __ ] II
more keeping with the descendence
premise regardless of the
inconsistencies with Carlos and dude
it's hard to deny how adorable this
truth talking canine is fairy godmothers
wand both descendants and the sequel
require characters to steal the magic
wand that belongs to the fairy godmother
who is also auradon prep
headmistress in the first movie the
retrieval of the wand is a result of the
original villains opportunistic thinking
taken advantage of Prince Ben's decision
to practice forgiveness and inclusion
instead the Evil Queen Jafar Cruella
Deville and of course
Maleficent take the chance to reclaim
their role as the enemy instructing and
pressuring their children to steal the
wand and reclaim power is a driving
force of the movie and the one takes on
a similar role in descendants - as uma
requires the wand in exchange for Ben's
safe release in the first movie the
ultimate fate of the one remains a
mystery until Ben's coronation however
in descendants - the characters
resourcefully utilize a 3d printer to
make a fake wand for Ben's ransom
the first inconsistency lies in why
characters with spells and superpowers
would need a 3d printer to make a fake
wand even if we disregard this detail
it's still unclear why the idea of
making a fake wand didn't occur to any
villains in the first movie switching
out the real wands for a fake line that
the coronation seems to us to be a much
more efficient way of attaining the real
deal bad villains like sweet sugar as
much fun as it is to watch mal freak out
over the sweet taste of strawberries
something doesn't quite add up when it
comes to what food is available to the
characters who have been banished and
isolated on the Isle of the Lost
we see the villains encounter unknown
food for the first time in descendants
when they are offered a feast of candy
in their limo ride to auradon their
excitement is unparalleled and the fact
that they have been deprived of sweets
of food all kids in teens crave add to
the injustice placed upon them simply
for the fact that they are parented by
the worst Disney villains imaginable
however this detail doesn't quite line
up in the scene when mouth first
encounters Terry mal is seen chewing on
gum appearing cool and aloof
when confronted by her ex-boyfriend she
even goes as far as discarding her
chewed up gum on the end of Harry's hook
how we wonder does now have gum on the
all of the lost if it's already been
established that sugar is a foreign
taste for villains
even if Mao had brought it back from
Oregon wouldn't Harry be freaked out by
the unknown substance in any case the
dietary restrictions on the Isle of lost
is definitely an inconsistency that just
doesn't add up want to know why dub
Cameron the star is the number one
inconsistency keep watching to find out
Green and means one inconsistency we
just have to mention has to do with
mouths eyes turning green and what that
might signify for her character at the
end of descendants once mal has chosen
the good side and her dragon mom has
been reduced to a lizard her eyes flash
to green since this is the first time we
see this in the movie the audience gets
a chance to interpret what this means
overwhelmingly the change in eye color
has been understood to indicate that
even though mal has chosen to be good
some darkness resides within her good
triumphs but ultimately we are all
inherently good and bad true to the
first movie descendants to seems to
consider the idea that our identity lies
in our decisions still the use of green
and mouth eyes seems to be inconsistent
mal chooses to be good and yet in the
sequel her eyes flashed constantly
especially while she's executing her
role as King Ben's girlfriend rather
than maintaining the lesson learned at
the end of the previous movie mal goes
Full Tilt's a blonde good girl and
naturally ends up feeling ill at ease
this causes us to wonder how the idea of
a bit of good and a bit of bad is
completely lost and then relearned to
the course of the sequel not that we're
complaining though we will happily watch
this lesson be learns yet again in the
third movie mixed-up magic one of the
best aspects of descendants and
descendants too is the inclusion of some
more underrated characters dags
appearance in descendants as dopey son
was among the most exciting characters
included of course dopey would
ironically have the most studious son
Plus Doug's lovable qualities and
infatuation
when Eevee makes him a staple character
to the movies similarily Drizzy
tremaine's appearance in dissonance -
was a welcome surprise to refresh your
memory
Drizzy is Druze Ella's daughter one of
the wicked stepsisters from Cinderella
it might be worth it to first point out
that while Jane and Drizzy come from the
same Disney tail Cinderella's daughter
is nowhere to be found
meanwhile mal gets her counterpart in
Audrey's character the biggest
inconsistency when it comes to Drizzy is
her role in the movie
Drizzy appears as mouths stylist when
she first returns to her original home
the Isle of the Lost
Drizzy immediately ascertain that mouth
is in need of a makeover and restores
her hair to its recognizable purple hue
why does mal need someone to change her
hairstyle when all she did in the first
movie was style the hair of her peers at
auradon prep if mal was unhappy with her
hair why didn't she just cast her usual
spell to turn it into the purple
luscious locks she desires we will never
understand this inconsistency but we are
happy that Drizzy is a new character J
and J far in descendants we get a taste
of the family tension that exists
between the Disney Villains
and their children and it creates a good
deal of intrigue for the audience we can
all identify with a period of time when
relationships might be strained with
parents understanding our identity apart
from our family is a normal and healthy
part of growing up therefore it makes
for a great conflict in the movie
however we couldn't help but notice that
while some characters like mal and
Maleficent or Evie and the Evil Queen
are explored others especially Jay and
Jafar are never really touched on in
fact and descendants we don't even see
or hear Jafar's reaction to his son
becoming a valuable asset to his sports
team
even in descendants - when jay has to
decide if it's worth risking his role on
the team to fight for the inclusion of
lani the first female athlete we are
never given insight on how Jafar feels
about the issue in fact we are never
given insight on Jafar's feelings of Jay
at all instead Jay exists as a character
who serves the sole purpose of rest
now although this seems like an
inconsistent effort with regard to
character development we can only hope
that it means it will be explored in a
third movie dove Cameron one
inconsistency you can count on when
young actors are involved is that from
movie to movie they will look different
it would be unreasonable to expect every
character to look exactly the same in
each movie however it's clear to see
that when it comes to mouth dove has
undergone more of a change than most of
her cast members there has been a lot of
speculation regarding this
transformation many sources contemplate
doves use of plastic surgery
entertaining the possibility of lip and
cheek injections as well as a potential
nose job whether these allegations are
true or false is inconsequential as dove
is free to do as she pleases when it
comes to her appearance all we can say
as a supportive audience is that dove is
beautiful in both descendants and
descendants - aside from the physical
change there's one more thing we notice
conveniently the final scene of
descendants tooth takes place during a
cotillion set on a boat making it ideal
for umas final transformation and the
ensuing battle what concerns us as an
inconsistency is after the battle while
Ben is still soaking wet
mouths dress and hair appears perfectly
restyled however in descendants after
mal plunges into the enchanted lake she
emerges wet and dripping the possibility
for a stylish transformation does not
present itself despite these
discrepancies we love dove as mouths do
we miss anything unusual between the two
movies let us know in the comments below
that's it for 10 inconsistencies between
descendants 2 and the first movie you
never saw for more stories like this
make sure to watch 10 descendants - fan
fiction stories that are better than the
original thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]